[Música]
dinamarca de canceló definitivamente el
uso de la vacuna de astrazéneca es la
primera nación en hacerlo y también fue
la primera en reportar un vínculo con
coágulos de sangre cerebrales su
autoridad del medicamento dice que hay
suficientes pruebas de los riesgos y
continuará su campaña de vacunación con
otras farmacéuticas
falleció en prisión a los 82 años
bernard madoff el exfinanciero condenado
por el mayor fraude en la historia de
wall street- estimado en unos 50.000
millones de dólares cumplía condena de
150 años en carolina del sur y el año
pasado había pedido libertad por una
enfermedad terminal tenemos reporte
desde nueva york
y en el caribe renuncio el primer
ministro de haití joseph y te dejo el
cargo sin dar explicaciones en un nuevo
episodio de la crisis política del país
y cuando la violencia y la miseria junto
a los secuestros sistemáticos empeoran
en el territorio más pobre de américa
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y a partir de este momento los
acompaño con las noticias del mundo en
france 24 iniciamos el informativo con
noticias de la vacunación contra el
virus del cob y de 19 dinamarca se
convierte en el primer país en suspender
de forma definitiva la utilización de la
vacuna de astrazéneca para combatir la
pandemia la nación europea tomó la
decisión al considerar que es probable
que exista una relación entre diversos
casos de trombosis detectados en
territorio europeo y el uso de este
medicamento además de considerar que la
situación epidemiológica en el país está
bajo control inicialmente el plan era
terminar la inmunización el 25 de julio
y sólo se retrasaría hasta agosto
informa natalia plazas
dinamarca se convirtió en el primer país
en dejar de utilizar por completo la
vacuna de astrazéneca las autoridades
sanitarias del país tomaron la decisión
tras estudiar un posible vínculo entre
casos de coágulos sanguíneos y el uso
del fármaco en el mes que ha pasado
investigamos intensamente estas señales
con expertos nacionales e
internacionales
güi jaf en gente fría ahora estamos
convencidos de la plausibilidad y la
causalidad de que este raro síndrome de
trombosis es muy grave sars y off de
schürrer
también tenemos una estimación de riesgo
de un en 40.000 de los vacunados este es
un nuevo conocimiento que no teníamos
cuando pusimos la vacuna de astrazéneca
en un ser bueno
de obstrucción y que la decisión causará
retrasos en la vacunación del país a
partir del 25 de julio y hasta
principios de agosto la semana pasada la
unión europea informó haber detectado un
posible vínculo entre el uso de la
vacuna y casos de trombosis cerebrales
aunque indicó que la mortalidad por kobe
19 comporta un riesgo mayor que los
posibles efectos secundarios de la
vacuna
dinamarca indicó haber tomado la
decisión en función de su bueno
de la pandemia y señaló que no descarta
su uso en el futuro
en una situación diferente no dudaría en
utilizar la vacuna de astrazéneca en
dinamarca entre en el transition a good
y si otros países continúan con extras
en ica en función de su situación y
contextos específicos por supuesto lo
entenderé my world of cost and testing
hasta el 4 de abril se habían detectado
169 casos de trombosis en europa tras la
administración de 34 millones de dosis
de la farmacéutica varios países
europeos ya han retomado la utilización
del fármaco muchos sin embargo lo
destinan a los mayores de 60 años al
considerar que éste conlleva riesgos
mucho menores para esta población que un
contagio por kobe 19
entretanto la presidenta de la comisión
europea úrsula van der leyen anunció que
los países de la unión recibirán 50
millones más de vacunas contra el
coronavirus producidas por facer y
bayonne tec en el segundo trimestre las
dosis que se esperaban inicialmente para
octubre se adelantarán para este mes en
compensación de los menores suministros
de astrazéneca por los casos de coágulos
cerebrales y de posibles problemas con
johnson y johnson por la misma razón por
otro lado se amplió el convenio con fai
será hasta 2023 y también se le dio luz
verde al pasaporte de vacunación en el
bloque europeo esther herrera nos amplía
desde bruselas
fisher se ha comprometido a adelantar 50
millones de dosis de su vacuna a partir
de este mismo mes de abril y hasta junio
en bruselas cree que así se puede
conseguir el 70 por ciento de europeos
inmunizados ya para el verano estos 50
millones de dosis adelantadas por facer
son aproximadamente el mismo número de
dosis que se había comprometido
hans en la vacuna de johnson and johnson
antes de que ayer anunciada que
paralizará la vacunación de momento a la
espera de analizar los posibles casos de
trombos y también en tras la inoculación
de su vacuna además la presenta de la
comisión europea o sola founder ley en
tal y como comentaba ha anunciado
también que ha comprado en 1.800
millones de dosis más de la vacuna de
facer hasta el año 2023 con la esperanza
de que se pueda inmunizar también a los
europeos ante las nuevas variantes o
bien en caso de que sea necesario
volverse para inmunizar este anuncio se
produce justo hoy cuando ya se han
producido 100 millones de vacunaciones
en la unión europea
la unión europea quiere a toda costa
acercarse un poquito más a la normalidad
bien con las vacunaciones pero también
facilitando los viajes por ello los
países europeos han dado hoy luz verde
al certificado digital en que una
persona antes de viajar tendrá que
confirmar si ha sido vacunada o bien
tiene un test negativo aún así aún falta
la negociación con el parlamento europeo
para que para el mes de junio ya pueda
entrar en vigor este certificado
en eeuu murió a los 82 años el ex
financiero bernie madoff responsable del
mayor fraude de la historia de wall
street por una estafa piramidal de
magnitudes millonarias
madoff a falleció en una cárcel federal
de carolina del sur donde cumplía una
condena de 150 años tras haberse
declarado culpable en 2009 de orquestar
una millonaria estafa
el año pasado madoff había solicitado
salir de la cárcel a causa de una
enfermedad terminal pero la petición le
fue negada desde nueva york en nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala nos dio más
detalles de la noticia y del perfil de
mala
y bernie madoff pasará a la historia por
ser el autor intelectual del mayor
fraude financiero que se ha vivido en
este país estafó cerca de 20 mil
millones de dólares a decenas de miles
de personas en cerca de 136 países made
off hizo una gran carrera financiera
aquí en wall street con clientes de la
talla del director de cine steven
spielberg o el actor kevin costner
además fue también presidente del nasdaq
durante varios años en la década de los
90 fue entonces cuando amasó gran parte
de su fortuna su estrategia consistió
básicamente en utilizar el dinero de sus
nuevos inversionistas para pagar a los
viejos inversionistas hizo creer a todo
el mundo que tenía en sus manos más de
65 mil millones de dólares pero lo
cierto es que dos tercios de ese dinero
estaban en su imaginación y el resto
pertenecía a sus clientes en a finales
del 2008 en diciembre del 2008 es
arrestado aunque él ya lo sabía porque
un día antes había confesado a sus
empleados que la empresa tenía unas
pérdidas de 50 mil millones
de dólares y que se iba a entregar a las
autoridades meses después en marzo del
2009 el mismo confiesa ante el juez
culpable de 11 delitos entre ellos
perjurio o lavado de dinero es entonces
cuando el juez le condena a 150 años de
prisión de los que ya había cumplido 12
en otras noticias el kremlin sostuvo
este miércoles que considera prematura
la posibilidad de una reunión con el
presidente de eeuu joe biden
luego de la propuesta desde washington
de una cumbre en un tercer país separa
desescalar la tensión en la frontera
ruso-ucraniana tras meses de tregua
volvieron las preocupaciones por el
movimiento constante de tropas a ambos
lados de los países y también por parte
de los aliados de la otan y de eeuu este
martes rusia envió 15 buques al mar
negro y washington movilizó dos barcos
de guerra que llegarían esta semana a la
zona
luego del anuncio del presidente de eeuu
joe biden de retirar sus tropas de
afganistán hoy alemania anunció que
también sincronizará su retirada al
igual que la otan
además tanto francia como reino unido-
conversarán para determinar si se suman
a la iniciativa el presidente joe biden
entregará más detalles este miércoles y
sostuvo que el proceso será gradual e
iniciaría antes de mayo para finalizar
el próximo 11 de septiembre cuando se
cumplen 20 años del atentado contra las
torres gemelas de nueva york y contra el
pentágono
en américa latina y el caribe la crisis
política y de seguridad sigue golpeando
haití el primer ministro de joseph joe
te presentó su dimisión al presidente de
job en el movice aunque no dio
explicaciones el cambio tiene como
objetivo abordar los graves problemas de
inseguridad en el país más pobre de
américa y es que el anuncio llega en
medio de una epidemia de secuestros por
parte de grupos criminales el último fue
el domingo cuando raptaron a 12 personas
siete religiosos entre ellos dos
franceses la iglesia convocó a un paro
laboral para el 15 de abril informe de
alva santana
la crisis de seguridad de políticas
sigue winston 2 en haití este miércoles
el primer ministro del país caribeño
josé couso anunció su renuncia sin dar
detalles
esta tarde presenté mi renuncia al
presidente de la república joven el mois
ha sido un honor servir a mi país como
primer ministro
agradezco a los miembros de mi gobierno
a los técnicos y a los financieros su
colaboración el presidente yo ven el
mois aceptó su renuncia y aseguró que la
decisión ayudaría a combatir la
inseguridad en el país ya resolver la
crisis política ya que goes no contaba
con el respaldo del parlamento
la renuncia del gobierno que acepte
permitirá abordar el flagrante problema
de la inseguridad y continuar las
discusiones con miras a lograr los
consensos necesarios para la estabilidad
política e institucional de nuestro país
el ministro josep lotes nombrado primer
ministro interino haití se encuentra
sumido en una serie de secuestros
sistemáticos perpetrados por grupos
criminales por lo que muchos ciudadanos
tienen miedo a salir a las calles
durante el primer trimestre de 2020 el
país registró 142 casos de secuestros
casi el triple que los 51 reportados en
el mismo período del año pasado todos
los segmentos de la población están
expuestos a este tipo de sucesos el
último secuestro fue el domingo cuando
retuvieron a 12 personas entre ellas
siete religiosos dos de los cuales son
franceses por lo que la iglesia hizo un
llamado al paro laboral este jueves 15
de abril los raptos indiscriminados han
generado varias protestas de la
población en los últimos meses que
reclama al gobierno que actúe
en enero de este año la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
otorgó medidas cautelares de protección
para un tinto care de 20 años en
nicaragua
el joven usa sus redes para criticar al
gobierno y ha sido arrestado en tres
ocasiones ahora afirma no tener miedo a
las amenazas que no paran
nuestro corresponsal en managua jorge
hurtado nos trae su historia
kevin monzón se define como un activista
digital es reconocido por sus sátiras
contra el gobierno de daniel ortega en
la red social tic tac
los tres arrestos pues ha sido terrible
para mí porque te puedo decir que me han
golpeado y también de igual manera me ha
amenazado directamente que me van a
matar que van a andar a el chipote
nuevamente que me calle que nos siga
viendo y todas esas cosas me dicen ellos
el joven [__] docter afirma que no teme
a las constantes amenazas y asedio de
parte de afines al gobierno con una
restricción general a protestar en las
calles las redes sociales se han
convertido en una ventana para mostrar
su descontento
exactamente falla donde ellos me
detuvieron y me pidieron por el nombre
completo bueno está bien perfecto vídeo
pero no me van a callar dónde vives te
estoy detenido a través de unas celdas
aguantando miles de cosas pero yo voy a
seguir siempre resistencia defensores de
derechos humanos temen nuevos arrestos
con la aprobación el año pasado de una
ley de ciberdelitos que según el
gobierno pretende proteger a los
usuarios de redes sociales existen
demasiado
y delitos cibernéticos que efectivamente
no tienen los suficientes argumentos
legales desde el código penal para poder
sancionarlos sin embargo lo que estamos
observando desde que esto es una pauta o
un arma que puede utilizar el gobierno
para seguir restringiendo sean
censurando lo que son las personas que
no están de acuerdo por razones
políticas si te puedo decir pues esta
ley quiere venir a callar el periodismo
quiere venir a callar a la gente que
esté informando quiere venir a callar al
pueblo porque está express está en las
redes sociales y por eso esa ley el
próximo mes de noviembre nicaragua
tendrá elecciones generales en un
ambiente muy polarizado por ahora este
tipo que juega a su libertad al subir un
nuevo vídeo
luto en níger por el fallecimiento de al
menos 20 niños la mayoría de ellos entre
los 3 y los 5 años tras un incendio en
una escuela primaria de niamey en la
emergencia los más pequeños no pudieron
correr para escapar 20 salones
terminaron bajo fuego esparcido por el
viento en un barrio humilde níger es uno
de los países más pobres del mundo y
para remediar la falta de aulas las
autoridades están construyendo miles de
salones improvisados con paja y madera
y los musulmanes del mundo viven los
primeros días del ramadán la
conmemoración más importante para el
islam que consiste principalmente en un
mes de ayuno y oración este periodo
sagrado está marcado por las medidas de
prevención contra el cob y 19 india
reportó un nuevo récord de contagios con
184 mil casos pero aún así se registran
grandes concentraciones en el continente
africano también se cuenta a un alto
número de musulmanes en países como
senegal donde cientos de fieles se
reunieron en mezquitas
y así llegamos al final del informativo
siga con nosotros también en france24
punto com y nos vemos más adelante
buenas tardes
[Música]